bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va pas
et d'emile turckheim emile durkheim et
locke français né en 1858 il est
considéré comme l'un des fondateurs
sinon le fondateur de la sociologie
moderne
il est celui qui a le plus contribué à
faire de la sociologie une discipline à
part entière une discipline scientifique
et si je crois légitime de parler d'un
sociologue sur une chaîne de philosophie
c'est parce que jusqu'au 19ème siècle
ciot logis et philosophie partageaient
un lien de parenté
le mot sociologie est relativement
récent il date du xviiie siècle
mais l'idée derrière ce mot elle existe
depuis bien plus longtemps
l'idée d'étudier les phénomènes sociaux
l'idée d'étudier la manière dont la
société influencent nos comportements
c'est quelque chose de très anciens
quand ristote définissez l'homme comme
un animal politique
quand platon estimait que la cité devait
imprimer dans le coeur des hommes
l'amour du vrai et du juste c'était une
manière de dire que les individus sont
en grande partie façonné par la société
dans laquelle ils vivent
et pourtant il ne nous viendrait pas à
l'esprit
de définir platon et aristote comme des
sociologues
leur intérêt pour la sociologie c'était
un intérêt d'ordre philosophique
à l'intérêt pour la question du rapport
entre l'individu et le collectif
qu'on s'intéresse à la manière dont nos
comportements sont influencés par notre
environnement social
dès lors qu'on reconnaît l'existence de
phénomènes collectifs et qu'on
s'interroge sur eux
on fait de la sociologie
la sociologie s'est littéralement
l'étude des faits sociaux
or à partir du moment où on vit en
société ce qui est a priori notre cas à
tous on n'échappe pas aux faits sociaux
nous sommes tous parties prenantes de
comportement de pratiquer de manière de
penser
qui sont largement déterminée par la
société dans laquelle nous vivons
mais il aura fallu attendre le 19e
siècle pour que cette influence du
social sur les individus fassent l'objet
d'une étude à part entière
il aura fallu attendre le 19e siècle
pour qu'on admette que les faits sociaux
n'était pas seulement un paramètre à
prendre en compte
était bel et bien une réalité objective
une réalité scientifique et ses lacs
intérieurs
un emile durkheim
turckheim et celui qui a voulu donner un
cadre scientifique à l'étude des faits
sociaux
pour le dire simplement il est celui qui
a voulu qu'on prenne la sociologie au
sérieux
qu'on la prenne au sérieux comme on
prenait au sérieux les autres sciences
la biologie la physique ou l'astronomie
rappelons qu'au 19e siècle il y à un
véritable engouement pour les sciences
la connaissance explose dans tous les
domaines
et tous les savants ils vont de leur
petite contribution
pasteur pose les bases de la
microbiologie
soit elle découvre l'électromagnétisme
mendeleïev élabore son tableau
périodique des éléments
darwin fait valider sa théorie de
l'évolution bref le 19e siècle le siècle
de l'envolée des sciences
pour ne pas dire de la fascination pour
les sciences
si on va même touché les artistes en
particulier les romanciers comme ceux-là
où nous passons par exemple
c'était par hasard si on les appelle des
écrivains naturalistes puisque le
naturaliste c'est celui qui pratique les
sciences naturelles
et notamment la biologie
les romans naturalistes sont remplies de
référence au domaine scientifique
on y évoque l'hérédité on y évoque l'
influence du milieu
et aulas a même sous titré ça sert et
des rougon-macquart histoires naturelles
et sociales d'une famille sous le second
empire
la littérature naturaliste c'est l'art
qui s'abreuve aux puits de la science et
si je parle de tout simple c'est pour
vous comprenez bien l'état d'esprit dans
lequel baignait emile dürckheim
lorsqu'il a émis le projet de faire de
la sociologie une science
c'était pour lui une manière de
participer à l'essor de l'esprit
scientifique qui animait le 19e siècle
et pour ça il fallait imiter le modèle
des autres sciences c'est à dire définir
un objet d'étude spécifique et mettre en
place une méthode rigoureuse qui allait
permettre de faire accepter la
sociologie au sein de la grande famille
des sciences
seulement voilà ce désir de turckheim le
désir d'instituer la sociologie comme
science allait se heurter à quelques
réticences
les réticences auquel dur car il va
répondre
et qu'on va essayer de résumer de
manière simple
la première et dix ans la plus facile à
comprendre c'est que à la différence des
autres sciences la sociologie ne porte
pas sur des réalités matérielles
qu'est ce que ça veut dire bien ça veut
dire qu un fait social ce n'est pas
quelque chose de palpable
un fait social
pas un objet concret or à l'excès
les mathématiques toutes les sciences en
vigueur au 19e siècle porté sur des
objets palpable
la matière et d'un objet palpable
les planètes sont des objets palpable
les organismes sont des objets palpable
on peut les toucher on peut les observer
au microscope
ou à la lunette astronomique on peut les
mesures et on peut les pesées les
décomposer
c'est concret
m un fait social ce n'est pas concret ce
n'est pas corporelle c'est très flou
canton
shi un fait social qu'est ce que c'est
concrètement un fait social
comment ça se détecte
ça se comporte
comment ça agit c'est un peu par
être très naïf comme questionnement
parce qu'à notre époque la sociologie
est bien installé parmi les sciences
mais au 19e siècle
ça n'avait rien d'évident parce qu'au
19e siècle
un scientifique ça travaille dans un
laboratoire
expérience sa fédé
kühl à partir d'observations mesurables
et qu'à cette époque
on ne voit pas très bien à quoi pourrait
ressembler le laboratoire d'un
sociologue
ni avec quels instruments il peut bien
étudié ces faits sociaux
donc c'est ça pour ainsi dire le premier
problème de la sociologie ou plus
exactement du projet de faire de la
sociologie une science
le caractère incorporels des faits
sociaux
problème
il y à un autre problème un problème
encore plus fondamentale littéralement
c'est à dire qui touchent au fondement
même de la démarche sociologique
ce problème c'est le fait que la
sociologie considère que ce sont les
faits sociaux qui façonnent les
individus
et non les individus
façonnent les faits sociaux
le poste
hic c'est finalement un renversement de
la perspective commune
la perspective commune est temps de dire
que ce sont les individus qui font la
société et non pas l'un vers ce
sont bien les individus qui s'assemblent
qui s'associent et qui en s'associant
créer des réalités sociales
les réalités sociales ne devrait donc
être rien de plus que la somme des
actions des individus
donc le deuxième problème de la
sociologie
c'est qu'elle tend à expliquer des
comportements individuels par des causes
extérieures à ces mêmes individus
et si on va au bout du raisonnement
c'est à dire si on admet que c'est la
société qui influence les individus et
non pas l' inverse
alors ça signifie que les individus ne
sont rien d'autre que le produit de leur
environnement
j n'irait aux individus leur liberté
alors maintenant qu'on a posé les deux
principales objections qui ont été
faites à la sociologie
on va voir comment dieu cay me répond
on va commencer par la première
objection première objection qui porte
sur le fait que les faits sociaux ne
sont pas des réalités matérielles
en somme c'est une objection assez
facile à résoudre en réalité parce que
si on y réfléchit
il y a des tas de choses que la science
étudie et qui ne sont pas matériel
rendre un exemple très simple
la trajectoire d'une planète autour du
soleil ce qu'on appelle l'orbité d'une
planète
bien leur vie d'une planète ça peut se
mesurer
on peut en mesurer le diamètre on peut
en mesurer la vitesse on peut en mesurer
l'inclinaison et pourtant l'orbité d'une
planète
c'était pas matériel
la trajectoire
parcourue par une planète autour du
soleil ce n'est pas quelque chose de
matériel
c'est le résultat d'une interaction
entre des objets matériels
et c'est pas pareil
donc on a bien affaire
un cas où la science et tu dis une chose
non matériel
alors comme je sais que tout le monde
n'est pas amateur l'astronomie on va
prendre un exemple encore plus simple
si vous prenez une pomme et que vous la
lâcher la pomme
tombé
tombé parce qu'elle est attirée par la
terre ça s'appelle la
son et lagrave
on physiquement parlant
une force
or cette force qui fait que la pomme
tombe par terre
on peut la mesurer
acculé à l'aide de formules
mathématiques donc la grève
sion on est bien d'accord que c'est très
réel
et pourtant ce n'est pas matériel
sont en elles-mêmes vous ne pouvez pas
l'observer
vous ne pouvez pas la voir vous ne
pouvez pas la toucher
ce que vous pouvez c'est en observer les
effets
par exemple si vous sautez du troisième
étage vous allez observer les effets de
la gravitation
mais vous n'allez pas observé la
gravitation elle même
parce qu'une force ne s'observe pas ce
sont ses effets qui s'observent et bien
1 ce que nous dit dürckheim c'est que un
fait social
c'est exactement la même chose un fait
social n'est pas une réalité matérielle
un fait social est une force qui agit
sur des réalités matérielles qui sont
les individus et qui se traduit
matériellement dans les usages et les
comportements de ces individus
et la même façon que la gravitation ne
se situe pas seulement dans la pomme qui
tombe mais se situe partout autour de
nous
de la même façon
les faits sociaux environnent les
individus et les soumettent à une
influence invisible en elle-même
donc si vous avez compris que ce n'est
jamais une force qu'on observe mais les
effets de cette force sur des objets
matériels
alors vous avez compris en quoi les
faits sociaux sont pour turckheim une
réalité agissante
bien qu'il ne soit pas une réalité
matérielle
la plus connue de turckheim celle par
laquelle il introduit sa méthode c'est
de dire il faut considérer les faits
sociaux comme des choses
et ceux qui n'ont pas compris cette
phrase
ou qui ont fait semblant de ne pas la
comprendre on reprochait à turckheim de
dire que les faits sociaux étaient des
choses matérielles
mais enfin il
n'est pas un idiot c'est bien que les
faits sociaux ne sont pas des choses
matérielles de même que la gravitation
n'est pas une chose matérielle
gravitation n'est pas une chose
matérielle que la gravitation n'existe
pas
et pas parce que les faits sociaux ne
sont pas des choses matérielles que les
faits sociaux n'existe pas
une chose nous dit dürckheim
c'est ce qui peut se connaître du dehors
la chose c'est ce qu'ils possèdent une
extériorité par rapport à l'esprit
ce critère de l'extériorité qui fait que
les faits sociaux doivent être
considérées comme un objet d'étude
scientifique
si vous préférez on peut étudier quelque
chose scientifiquement qu'à partir du
moment où cette chose se trouve face à
nous
et non pas à l'intérieur de nous
c'est pour ça que selon dürckheim
l'introspection n'est pas une méthode
scientifique
parce que dans l'introspection
des informations ce mélange eau
les sentiments vient de se mêler à
l'analyse et ça ça marche pas on ne fait
pas de l'acier
sur de la subjectivité
on fait de la science sur de
l'objectivité
l'objectivité s'est littéralement ce qui
existe comme objet
ceux qui existent indépendamment de
notre esprit et de notre intériorité
les faits sociaux existent en dehors de
notre esprit ils sont une réalité
extérieure aux individus autrement dit
une réalité objective et à ce titre ils
sont éligibles au statut d'objet
scientifique
alors pour qu'il n'y ait pas
on dut sur ce que dürckheim appel fait
social on va quand même donné quelques
exemples
la langue que nous parlons par laquelle
nous communiquons les uns avec les
autres
c'est un fait social
rappelons que communiquer ses avoirs en
commun
la monnaie que nous utilisons
par laquelle nous interagissons sur le
plan économique
c'est un fait social
et radis
nous partageons et fêtes de noël ou du
nouvel an
le 1er avril le 14 juillet ce sont des
faits sociaux
donc ici j'ai pris des exemples de faits
sociaux nationaux ou supra nationaux
mais il existe des faits sociaux
transfrontalier
par exemple une religion
est un fait social
c'est un fait social puisque la religion
repose sur des croyances communes qui
débouche sur des pratiques communes
une mode c'est un fait social c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que ça s'appelle une
mode masculin un mode c'est une manière
d'être
1 une mode c'est une manière d'être
collective
et une mode ces quelques
ce qui relie des individus partageant
les mêmes goûts
partageant les mêmes codes et qui va
influencer leur comportement
par exemple leur comportement
vestimentaire
ou leurs comportements linguistiques
et vous voyez là encore que tous les
exemples que je viens de vous donner ce
ne sont pas des choses matérielles
une langue monnaie une tradition ce ne
sont pas des objets matériels
ce sont des choses qui agissent sur les
entités matériel que sont les individus
et qui se manifeste dans des usages et
des comportements qui eux sont
directement observables
il ya donc le fait social et la
manifestation du fait social à travers
des comportements
et le travail du sociologue c'est
d'étudier le fait social à travers les
comportements par lesquels ils se
manifestent
turckheim définit le fait social de la
manière suivante il écrit et fait social
toute manière de faire fixer ou non
susceptibles d'exercer sur l'individu
une contrainte extérieure ou bien encore
qui est général dans l'étendue d'une
société donnée
tout en ayant une existence propre
indépendante de ces manifestations
individuelles
vous remarquerez dans cette phrase
l'expression existence propre
ça c'est très important dire que les
faits sociaux ont une existence propre
c'est dire qu'ils existent au delà de
chaque individu qui le fait exister
propre d'un phénomène collectif c'est de
ne pas se réduire à la somme des agents
qui le composent
si je prends l'exemple de la police la
police c'est bien une corporation qui ne
se réduit pas à la somme des personnes
qui ont font partie
la preuve c'est que les policiers
deux se renouvelle
quand les uns partent à la retraite
d'autres arrivent pour les remplacer
si bien qu'aucun des policiers qui
constitue aujourd'hui le fait social
police n'ont été membre il ya cent ans
et pourtant il y à 100 ans le fait
social police existait tout autant
qu'aujourd'hui
d'un point de vue sociologique on dira
donc que la police est un fait social
qui existe au delà des individus qui le
constituent
alter eastick fondamentale du fait
social selon dürckheim c'est son
autonomie par rapport à ses incarnations
individuel
c'est son indépendance par rapport aux
individus qui le constituent comme
réalité temporellement déterminer la
phrase de turckheim qui résume le mieux
cette approche c'est un tout n'est pas
identique à la somme de ses parties
et il ajoute il est quelque chose
d'autre et dont les propriétés diffère
de celle que présente les parties dont
il est composé
et là on touche véritablement au coeur
de la thèse de turckheim
ce qui est vraiment pour lui le socle de
sa démarche
à voir que la combinaison des individus
au sein d'un collectif produit toujours
des propriétés nouvelles par rapport aux
individus qui composent ce collectif
c'est cette production de propriétés
nouvelles qui définit scientifiquement
le fait social
le tout présente des caractéristiques
qu'on ne retrouve pas chez les membres
de ce tout
c'est ce qui fait par exemple que
lorsque vous vous retrouvez avec les
membres de votre groupe
le groupe a mis le groupe famille
le groupe collègues de travail vous
allez parfois adopté un comportement
dr y est pas nécessairement en tant qu
individu isolé
vous allez fonctionner à l'intérieur de
ce groupe selon les codes et les usages
qui définissent le groupe
et la conclusion qu'en tire dürckheim
c'est que les usages qui caractérise un
groupe
ne sont pas les usages de chaque membre
du groupe qui se trouve coïncider comme
par magie
les usages des membres d'un groupe ce
sont les usages du groupe lui même les
usages propres au groupe en tant que
groupe
est ce qu'on appelle les phénomènes de
groupe où les comportements de groupe
ce sont des comportements que les
membres du groupe n'adopterait pas en
tant qu'individu à l'extérieur du groupe
c'est un phénomène sociologique
on peut
aux supporters de foot qui va voir jouer
son équipe au stade etc y incorporer
dans le groupe de supporters la criée va
chanter
sulte et l'équipe adverse
parce que c'est comme ça que le groupe
fonctionne
alors attention on prête souvent au
phénomène de groupe des attributs
négatif
au sens où l'individu peut en venir à
abandonner son libre arbitre pour se
fondre dans la mentalité du groupe
auquel il appartient
c'est ce qu'explique gustave lebon dans
son livre psychologie des foules qui
tend à montrer que noyés dans la masse
du collectif l'individu perd son
discernement et en a des comportements
primitifs
c'est vrai
et l'appartenance au groupe c'est aussi
ce qui produit de la
arrêté
c'est aussi ce qui produit de la
communion et donc pour revenir à
kyle c'est vraiment ça l'idée qu'il
cherche imposé
le fait que les faits sociaux produisent
des phénomènes nouveaux qui ne se
réduisent pas à la somme de ses éléments
constitutifs
le fait social et générateurs d'usagé et
de comportement qui n'existe pas en
dehors de ce fait social
en d'autres termes le fait social est
une réalité à part entière
alors si vous avez bien suivi le
raisonnement de turckheim
peut-être aurez-vous déjà deviner sa
réponse à la deuxième objection deuxième
objection qui consistait à dire que ce
sont les individus qui créent les faits
sociaux et non les faits sociaux qui
façonnent les individus
1 / dürckheim ne nie pas totalement
cette objection
ce sont effectivement les individus qui
créent les faits sociaux au sens où les
faits sociaux n'apparaissent pas tout
seul
les faits sociaux ne tombe pas du ciel
ils sont bel et bien créé par les hommes
mais ce que dit dürckheim c'est que les
faits sociaux rétro agissent sur les
individus
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que les faits
sociaux rétro agissent sur les individus
bien ça veut dire qu en se formant et en
se développant
le fait social acquiert une force
et que cette force va faire pression sur
les individus qui composent ce fait
social
turckheim écrit explicitement et dit les
faits sociaux possède un pouvoir
coercitif
qu'est ce que ça veut dire coercitif ça
veut dire qu'ils exercent une contrainte
les faits sociaux exerce une contrainte
sur les individus qui les pousse à se
conformer au fait social
et c'est pour ça que finalement la
réponse de turckheim à la deuxième
objection découle de sa réponse à la
première
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
comprendre en quoi les faits sociaux
façonnent les individus
si on n'a pas compris que les faits
sociaux étaient des réalités extérieur
est indépendante des consciences
individuelles
les individus créé les faits sociaux et
en créant les faits sociaux
ils créent sans savoir une force
collective autonome désormais capable de
les contraindre dans leur usage est dans
leur comportement
on peut illustrer sa part une image très
simple
si vous vous associez avec d'autres
personnes pour créer une entreprise
à ce moment là vous n'êtes plus
seulement des individus
vous devenez des associés
deco sociétaires
mais donc à partir du moment où vous
devenez qu aux sociétaires vous créez
une nouvelle couche de réalité qui
n'existait pas quand vous étiez tout
seul
vous créez des obligations
créer des responsabilités
s'incarner dans des comportements
concret la locale
local des réunions de travail
un bilan
table donc quand vous créez une société
vous créez un fait social qui va avoir
un pouvoir coercitif sur vous
vous créez une
vos épaules
la pression de devoir remplir votre
fonction
de faire correctement votre travail
date un trou
jacques cif parce que derrière il y à
l'entreprise dont vous ne faites plus
que vous voulez en vous associant avec
d'autres individus
vous avez créé une entité collective a
fait social donc et ce fait social exige
maintenant de vous que vous obéissent y
ait un certain nombre d'impératifs
en vous associant
vous avez produit un cortège de
contraintes
un cortège d'obligations qui va faire
pression sur votre comportement
ces 5
calme à ses contemporains cette idée que
ce que les individus créé s'étend au
dollar de ce qu'ils ont créé
et qu'il n'ya donc pas d'incompatibilité
entre le fait que les faits sociaux soit
le produit des individus et le fait que
les individus soit en même temps sous la
contrainte des faits sociaux et du coup
ce que dit dürckheim
ce n'est pas que les individus sont
privés de tout pouvoir d'action
ou de leur libre arbitre
ce qu'il dit c'est que l'effet sociaux
exerce une contrainte sur les individus
que si les individus cherchent à
résister à cette contrainte
ou à lui échapper ils seront sanctionnés
on parlait tout talent
or des phénomènes de groupe de la
pression du groupe
la pression du groupe c'est une force
coercitive
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il est
impossible pour l'individu de résister
ou de désobéir à cette pression
ça veut dire s'il le fait
s'il ne suit pas le mouvement impulsé
par le groupe le groupe cherchera à
s'imposer à lui
on trouve ça parfois vous savez dans les
bandes d'amis à l'école
amis entre guillemets
demande à celui qui veut faire partie du
groupe de faire quelque chose qu'il n'a
pas du tout envie de faire
l'enfant alors le choix entre deux
options soit il obéit au groupe il peut
l'intégrer
soit il lui désobéit et il en est exclu
donc voyez que c'est plus compliqué que
de dire
l'individu n'a pas le choix
non ce n'est pas que l'individu n'a pas
le choix
c'est justement qu'il a le choix mais
que ce choix un coup un coût social
les pactes les individus n'ont pas le
choix c'est que le fait social parce
qu'il possède un pouvoir contraignant
une force coercitive cette force place
l'individu devant un choix
la conformation au fait social ou la
sanction
le prix à payer pour résister à la force
du fait social
c'est la sanction sociale
bien que cette sanction n'a pas besoin
d'être physiquement violente
elle a juste besoin d'être socialement
efficiente
on va prendre un exemple images
et qu'à partir de demain vous décidé de
payer tout ce que vous achetez avec
débit
monopoly pourquoi pas le droit d'essayer
on voit bien qu est ce qui va se passer
bien déjà il va se passer que les gens
vont rigoler
ils vont se
je vous hais
vous n'avez pas votre carte bancaire sur
vous ben il est possible que la police
nous embarque
ou que vous ayez à gérer le
mécontentement du commerçant à qui vous
devez de l'argent
dans tous les cas qu'il y ait sanction
par la moquerie par la loi ou par la
violence il y aura sanction la sanction
c'est quand ça marche pas l'argent étant
un fait social puisque c'est une réalité
qui existe indépendamment des individus
et qu'en même temps il ne jouit de son
autorité que parce qu'il est utilisé par
une masse collective
une masse qui le reconnaît comme
possédant une valeur
et bien si vous refusez de vous
conformer à ce fait social
vous en paierez la sanction à savoir
possibilité d'acheter quoi que ce soit
c'est là que se trouve la pression du
fait social
son caractère coercitif ce n'est pas
qu'il vous force c'est qu'il fait en
sorte qu'il vous soit impossible de
faire autrement
même chose si vous décidez que désormais
vous parlerai à tout le monde en araméen
là encore vous pouvez tenter le coup
vous pouvez même essayer d'en faire la
nouvelle langue officielle d'en faire à
nouveau fait social
y en a qui ont réussi je cite le système
de signes dont je me sers pour exprimer
ma pensée le système de money que
j'emploie pour payer mes dettes
les instruments de crédit que j'utilise
dans mes relations commerciales les
pratiques suivies dans ma profession
fonctionne indépendamment des usages que
j'en fais
comprennent les uns après les autres
tous les membres dont est composé la
société ce qui précède pourrait être
répétée à propos de chacun d'eux voilà
donc des manières d'agir de penser et de
sentir qu'ils présentent cette
remarquable propriété qu'elle existe en
dehors des consciences individuelles
non seulement ces types de conduite ou
de pensées sont extérieurs à l'individu
mais ils sont doués d'une puissance
impérative et coercitives en vertu de
laquelle il s'impose à lui
qu'ils le veuillent ou non
sans doute quand je me conforme de mon
plein gré cette coercition ne se fait
pas ou ce fait peut sentir
il est temps inutile
mais elle n'en est pas moins un
caractère intrinsèque de ces faits et la
preuve c'est qu'elle s'affirme dès que
je tente de résister
si je ne me soumet pas aux conventions
du monde 6 ans m'habille en jeu ne tient
aucun compte des usages suivi dans mon
pays et dans ma classe le rire que je
provoque l'éloignement où l'on me tiens
produise quoi que d'une manière plus
atténué les mêmes effets qu'une peine
proprement dit
ailleurs la contrainte pour n'être qu'un
direct dans l'est pas moins efficace
je ne suis pas obligé de parler français
avec mes compatriotes ni d'employer les
mots n'est légale mais il est impossible
que je fasse autrement
si j'ai essayé d'échapper à cette
nécessité ma tentative échouerait
misérablement alors même que je puis
m'affranchir de ces règles et les
violets avec succès ce n'est jamais sans
être obligé de lutter contre elle
quand même elles sont finalement vaincu
elles font suffisamment s'en tirent leur
puissance contraignante par la
résistance qu'elle oppose
il n'y a pas de novateur même heureux
dont les entreprises ne viennent se
heurter à des oppositions de ce genre
la pression du fait social c'est ce qui
fait que les individus se contraignent
eux mêmes à travers ce qu'il crée
il n'y a qu'à voir certains couples dans
lesquels le fait d'être en couple crée
davantage de contraintes pour ne pas
dire de problèmes qu'il n'en résout
le couple c'est un fait social dans la
mesure où le couple crée une série de
contraintes et d'obligations qui
s'impose aux deux partenaires et qui
s'ils ne sont pas respectées entraîne la
fin du couple
donc vous voyez que qu'endurent cas il
parle du pouvoir contraignant du fait
social
c'est très concret
contraignant
turckheim nous dit que plus on lui
résiste plus elle s'impose
pouvoir contraignant n'est pas
nécessairement ressentie par les
individus
du fait que nous y sommes largement
préparé de par notre éducation
les ducs
on sait le processus d'intériorisation
des faits sociaux
c'est l'un des points de convergence
entre dürckheim et freud eu l'idée que
les individus intériorise les normes et
les contraintes de la vie sociale à
travers le processus éducatif
ce qui fait que bien souvent on ne se
rend même pas compte qu une force
contraignante plane au dessus de nos
têtes
on lui obéit
thud l'habitude c'est ceux qui habitent
nous
alors c'est intéressant parce que
souvent on entend dire que la sociologie
prouve l'existence d'un déterminisme
social
c'est le sens du deuxième volet de la
critique adressée à la sociologie
selon laquelle la sociologie n'irait le
libre arbitre des individus
bien ce n'est pas tout à fait ce que
nous dit turckheim
que nous dit dürckheim c'est que
chiots sont dotés d'un pouvoir de
contrainte
contrainte lui même facilité par
l'éducation
et qu'il se traduit dans l'existence de
phénomènes collectifs
statistiquement observable
ça selon dürckheim ce n'est pas la
définition du déterminisme parce que le
des thermes
nice mme
sion philosophique
or la science n'a pas à se prononcer sur
des positions philosophiques
la science doit se borner à étudier les
faits
et d'ailleurs si vous lisez les règles
de la méthode sociologique
vous verrez que la seule fois où le mot
déterminisme apparaît c'est justement
dans une phrase ou dürckheim écrit je
cite la sociologie n'a pas à prendre
parti entre les grandes hypothèses qui
divise les métaphysiciens
pas plus qu'à affirmer la liberté que le
déterminisme
récent
c'est très intéressant parce qu'en
faisant cette précision dürckheim montre
son attachement à l'objectivité
scientifique
il montre son refus que la sociologie
bascule dans l'idéologie
et ça c'est fondamental
basculer dans l'idéologie ça signifie
projeté sur un fait social la
signification qu'on voudrait qu'il est
ça signifie extrapoler les résultats
d'une expérience au delà de son champ de
validité
c'est quelque chose qu'on observe
beaucoup à notre époque le fait de
recourir à la sociologie non pas pour
rendre compte des faits mais pour étayer
un discours
non pas comme une science descriptive
mais comme un outil prescriptif
outil de diffusion d'opinions
or ce que dit dürckheim
que lorsqu'on fait la sociologie sans
colmater l'encadreur idéologique de ce
qu'on étudie
sans respecter ce que max weber rappelé
le principe de neutralité axiologique
à ce moment là on ne sait plus de la
science
et autre chose de la politique ou de la
morale alors on peut trouver ça naïf de
considérer qu'il soit possible de faire
de la sociologie sans idéologie
c'est à dire de croire qu'on puisse
s'extraire de ses propres schémas de
représentation lorsqu'on étudie un
phénomène social
mais ce que dit dürckheim
c'est que c'est justement ça le principe
de la science se
haché de soi même
et que si on n'est pas dans cette
attitude
dans cette attitude d'explorateurs qui
ignore tout de ce qu'il s'apprête à
découvrir
alors on n'est pas fait pour la science
le scientifique doit être en mesure de
produire des démonstrations
raisonnement
pas d intuition intellectualiser
ce que préconise turckheim dans l'étude
des faits sociaux
c'est une innocence épistémologique
celle appliquée
son d'une méthode rationnelle qui ne
soient pas guidés par le désir de
confirmation mais par l'esprit de
découverte
il en appelle à une humidité de la
recherche et à une conscience du
caractère infiniment complexe de ce que
le scientifiques étudient
je cite c'est ap
si nous entrevoyons de la manière la
plus confuse et souvent même la plus
inexacte
les véritables raisons qui nous ont
déterminé à agir et la nature de notre
action déjà alors qu'il s'agit
simplement de nos démarches privées
nous savons bien mal les mobiles
relativement simple qui nous guide
nous nous croyons désintéressée alors
que nous agissons en égoïste
nous croyons obéir à la haine alors que
nous cédons à l'amour à la raison alors
que nous sommes les esclaves de préjugés
irraisonnée
comment donc aurions-nous la faculté de
discerner avec plus de clarté les causes
autrement complexe dont procèdent les
démarches de la collectivité
car à tout le moins chacun de nous on y
prend part que pour une infime partie
nous avons une multitude de
collaborateurs et ce qui se passe dans
les autres conscience nous échappe
notre raid n'implique donc aucune
conception métaphysique aucune
spéculation sur le fond des êtres
ce qu'elle réclame c'est que le
sociologue se met dans l'état d'esprit
où son physiciens chimistes
physiologiste quand il s'engage dans une
région encore inexplorés de leur domaine
scientifique
il faut qu'en pénétrant dans le monde
social il est conscient ce qu'il pénètre
dans l'inconnu
il faut qu'ils se sentent en présence de
faits dont les lois sont aussi
insoupçonnées que pouvait l'être celle
de la vie quand la biologie n'était pas
constituée
il faut qu'ils se tiennent prêts à faire
des découvertes qui le surprendront et
le dé concerteront
or il s'en faut que la sociologie en
soit arrivé à ce degré de maturité
intellectuelle
tandis que le savant qui étudie la
nature physique a le sentiment très vif
des résistance qu'elle lui oppose et
dont il a tant de peine a triomphé il
semble en vérité que le sociologue se
meuvent au milieu de chose immédiatement
transparente pour l'esprit
tant est grande les ans avec laquelle on
le voit résoudre les questions les plus
obscurs dans l'état actuel de la science
nous le savons véritablement pas ce que
sont même les principales institutions
sociales comme l'état où la famille le
droit de propriété ou le contrat la
peine et la responsabilité
nous ignorons presque complètement les
causes dont elles dépendent les
fonctions qu'elle remplisse les lois de
leur évolution
c'est à peine si sur certains points
nous commençons à entrevoir quelques
lueurs
et pourtant il suffit de parcourir les
ouvrages de sociologie pour voir combien
est rare le sentiment de cette ignorance
et de ses difficultés
non seulement on se considère comme
obligé de dogmatisme et surtout les
problèmes à la fois mais on croit
pouvoir en quelques pages où en quelques
phrases atteindre l'essence même des
phénomènes les plus complexes
c'est dire que de semblables théorie
exprime non les faits qui ne saurait
être épuisée avec cette rapidité mais
l'après notion camps avaient l'auteur
antérieurement à la recherche
pour dürckheim la sociologie doit
emprunter les mêmes chemins
elle doit recourir aux mêmes méthodes
j'aime la même attitude que dans les
sciences naturelles
il est en cela l'héritier du positivisme
d'auguste compte
le positivisme désignant le projet de ne
s'en remettre coffey
de laisser de côté les hypothèses
métaphysique
ne peuvent qu'en tâche et l'examen des
faits
la question est
ouah
table dès lors qu'on touche à l'humain
et lors qu'on touche à la substance même
de ce qui nous constitue
vont nous le pouvoir
soustraire
propre subjectivité
quand etc
que l'objectivité net
objectivité que du point de vue de notre
subjectivité
c'était une
de nous mettre en garde contre l'orgueil
euse illusion de l'omniscience
la plus dangereuse des ignorances
celle qui ne
et de ce qu'elle ignore
dur quand même
sibilité d'une objectivité scientifique
se méfie de la tentation de
l'omniscience
il sait
- nous aimons trouver des explications
toutes faites aux choses
et à quel point nos conclusions précède
souvent nos raisonnements
à quel point nos raisonnements sont
souvent les échafaudages de nos
certitudes
alors si nous sommes
soumis à cette tentation
soumis
désir de plaquer sur les faits
propres certitudes
pour les faire triompher au pour nous
rassurer
domestique on sait tentation en ou rap
que face à celui qui croit savoir
c'est un pouvoir que de savoir dire
je ne sais pas je vous remercie
[Musique]